Herkese selamlar sevgili 9. sınıflar
nasılsınız bakalım? Umarım keyifler
yerinde. Her şey yoluna gidiyordur. E
artık eşlik benzerliğe başlıyoruz. 19.
dersimize geldik. Nereden geldik? Tabii
ki de Mortosuncuk elimizde. 19. dersi
açıyoruz. Eşlik benzerlik kısmını iki
derste yapacağız. 19 ve 20. derslerimiz
olacak. Şimdi 19. Yani girişimizi bir
yapıyoruz. Sen önünde kitabın, ben
karşımda ekranda. Birlikte bireysel ders
çalışması gibi başlayalım. Haydi o zaman
geçtik. Bu arada hala değilsen abone
olmayı lütfen unutma. Bizler için çok
kıymetli, çok değerli ve aynı zamanda da
videoyu beğenerek bizlere de destek
olabilirsiniz. Sizlerin şöyle bir
enerjisini alayım. O like'ları bir
görelim. Hadi bakalım. Şimdi öncelikle
üçgenlerin eş olma koşullarından
bahsedelim. Tabii ki bu mevzuları
biliyorsun az çok. 8. sınıfta da
görmüştük. İki üçgenin köşeleri arasında
birebir eşleme yapıldığında üçgenlerin
karşılıklı kenar uzunlukları ve
karşılıklı açılarının ölçüleri eşitse
bak önemli detay geldi. Karşılıklı kenar
uzunlukları ve karşılıklı açıların
ölçüleri eşit ise bu üçgende ne diyoruz?
Eş diyoruz. Sembolü de bizim için
önemli. Eşittirin üstünde bir şöyle yan
yatmış s harfimiz var. Şimdi eşitlik
benzerlikte ne yaptık sana? 8. sınıfta
da bunu üstüne basa basa 9800 kere
söyledik. Eşlik ya da benzerlik
mevzusunda sıralama
çok önemli. En önemli mevzu bu.
Dolayısıyla eşlik ilişkisinin sembol
temsilinde karşılıklı köşelerin aynı
sırada yazıldığına dikkat etmelisin.
Şimdi biz bu şekilde gördüysek o zaman e
ne anlayacağız hocam? Burada her
sıradaki karşısındaki aynı sıradaki
arkadaşlar eşit olacak. açılar. Mesela
1inci sırada A var. O zaman D açısı da
aynı olmalı. Çünkü ikisi de 1inci
sırada. 2inci sırada B açısı, E açısı B,
E aynı olacak. Ya da kenar uzunlukları.
Bak mesela bunu nereden çıkarabilirim?
İlk iki harf. Neyi oluşturuyor sana?
AB'yi. Karşıda ilk iki harf D E. A B D
Eşit olacak. Madem eşlik var sizin
aranızda. O zaman her şeyiniz eşit
olacak. Şimdi şöyle çıtır çerek
sorularımıza hemen geçelim. 11 tane soru
var. İlerleyen safhalarda darbeli
sorular geliyor. Tamam mı? Şimdi bir
eşlik ilişkimiz var. AB'yi, 4, F'yi 10,
12 bunları vermişiz. Uzunlukları
verilmeyen kenarları bulacağız. E madem
eşsiniz siz, ben önce açılarınızı
yerleştireyim. A açısı çizgi, D açısı
çizgi. 1inci sıradakiler. İkinciler B
nokta, 2inci E nokta, 3üncüler C F. C'ye
2, F'ye de iki çizgi attım. Eşliğimi
gösterdim. Şimdi tabii bunların
kenarları da bu açıların gördüğü kenar
uzunlukları gibi de düşünebilirsin.
Mesela bak iki çizgi 4'ü görüyor. O
zaman burada da iki çizgi 4'ü görecek.
Ya da ne bileyim burada nokta 10'u
görüyor. Bildiklerimin üstünden
gidiyorum hemen. Nokta 10'u görecek. E
diğer kenara da 12 kaldı. Yani 4 10 12
üçgeniymiş. Verilmeyen kenarları buldum.
Yallah. 2inci sorudayım. Şimdi yine bir
eşliğimiz var. Hemen yazıyoruz. Birinci
sırada K. K açısını 92 gördüm. Hemen
gidiyorum. Diğerine de de 92 yazıyorum.
L P L açımız. E bilmiyoruz. Karşıda P'yi
de bilmiyormuşuz. Tüh be. Birer çizgi
atıp geçtik. Muğla Rize. Şimdi Rize'yi
biliyoruz. 36. O zaman Muğla da ne
diyoruz? 36°. E 3. açıyı bulduk. Nedir
3üncü açımız? İkisini topla 180'den
çıkar. 92 36laştırdın
180'den 128'i çat diye çıkarttın 52.
Dolayısıyla 3üncü açılarımız da 52°
olacakmış. Kimi soruyorsun sen bana?
KLM. KLM
52°
ve Rap. Rap nerede? R P yani 92. 52 ile
92'nin doplaşmasını sormuş. Dolayısıyla
yanıtı 144° verdim. Geçtim. Anlaştık.
Şimdi detaya gidelim. Kenar kenar kenar
eşliği. Eşliklerimizin çeşitleri var.
Birincisi bu. 3 tane olacak. Birinciyle
başlıyoruz. Şimdi üç kenar uzunluğu
bilinen biliyorsun tek bir üçgen
çizebiliyorduk. Bu bilgiye sahibiz.
Dolayısıyla kenar uzunlukları aynı olan
iki üçgene eş diyebiliriz rahatlıkla.
Tamam. Şimdi burada da gördüğün üzere
kenar uzunları eşit oldu. Sadece bak
kenarlarını gördüm. Açılara bakmadan
bile şak diye hemen eşitliği
yapıştırabilirsin. A B C DF eşitliğimiz
var. Soru üstünden gidelim hemen.
Yaklaş. 3. soruma bakıyorum. Şimdi birer
dik üçgen verilmiş. İşte diklikleri
söylüyor. BC ED'ye eşit demiş. Dikkat.
BC kenarımı şöyle taradım. Kırmızı
arkadaş. Ben bunu bulurum ya. Dur sakin.
Burası dik üçgen değil miydi?
E burada hipotenüs var değil mi? Şu
hipotenüs Pisagor var. Hipotenüs 90'ın
karşısı 9 kenar uzunluğunda. Dik
kenarlardan biri de 4. Patlat Pisagoru.
4ün karesi + BC'nin kares
9un kares 81 yazdım. Hatta bu da direkt
16. Niye öyle yazdıysak 81'i 16'ya
şutla. Şöyle karşıya daha doğrusu 81'in
yanına 16'yı şutladım. Burası 5 7 1 6
mı? √65 ne çıkacağı çok önemli değil.
√65 böyle kalsın. Şimdi onun dışında ne
var? Bu arada hala eşik benzerlikten
bahsetmedik farkındasın değil mi? BC
ED'ye eşitmiş. Dur ED'yi de bulmuşuz o
zaman. Niye söylemiyorsunuz? Şu arkadaşı
da bulmuşuz. Sen de neymişsin? √65.
Şimik 4'ler verilmiş. İkisi de yazıyor.
5 verilmiş. Tamam. Eee ne yapacağız
hocam? Şimdi olaya iyice dalacağız.
Şimdi gençler burada eşlikten
bahsedebilir miyiz? Öncelikle ikisi de
dik üçgen. Tamam. Dik kenarlarımı
görüyorsun. Burası 4, burası √65.
E Pisagordan dolayı burası da 9.
Diğerinde de aynısı olacak. 4 √65.
Pisagordan dolayı burayı da ne
bulacaksın? 9 bulacaksın. Dolayısıyla
hemen 9'umu yapıştırır uzar giderim.
Haydi bakalım devam. Bunlar iyiz sorular
ama son 34 soruda birazcık e strese
gireceğiz. Şimdi ABC üçgenim var. C
mesela strese gireceğimiz sorulardan
biri de bu. Değişik bir soru daha
doğrusu. Şimdi C köşesi etrafında saat
yönünde 80° döndürdüm. Biz size boşuna
mı öğrettik? Öteleme dönme yansıma
dönmesini kullanıyoruz. 80° döndüğünde
işte B noktası B üssü A da A üssü
oluyormuş. B üssü C A üssü 108 verilmiş.
Ben burayı önce bir göstereyim bak. B
üssü C, A üssü. Yani şu açı tamamı 108
dereceymiş. X'in kaç derece olduğu
soruluyor. Bak şimdi ne yapacağız ya?
Bakalım. Dalalım soruya. Öncelikle
herhangi bir bak yine eşlik benzer
herhangi bir şeyden bahsetmemiş. Yazılı
da çıktı bu soru. Ne yapacaksın? Bir
kere bir önceki ders çok ciddi üstüne
yine vurgulayarak anlattık. Dönmede
şekil eee içerik olarak yani açıları
değişmez. Çünkü ne yapıyorsun? Sen bir
şekli sadece şöyle döndürüyorsun.
Kenar uzunlukları, açıları aynen gittiği
yere de taşınıyor.
Dolayısıyla ben bunu kullanmam lazım. Ne
yapıyorum peki? Ne yapacaksın hocam?
Hadi biliyoruz. Tamam. Ne yapacağız
şimdi? Bak A açısı
X derece ise affedersin ama döndüğünde
bir şey değişmeyecek. Yani sen burada da
x derecesin. Bu arada dönme olayını
anladınız değil mi? Bak normalde ABC
üçgenim şu. Tamam mı? C köşesini şuraya
çiviledik ve şöyle döndürüyoruz.
Döndürmemiz sonucunda oluşuyor bu
arkadaş. Anlaştık. Dolayısıyla A açısı
X, A üssü açısı da yani gittiği yerde de
X. E B açısı hadi ona da M diyelim.
Tamam mı? M. E o zaman şurası da M
olmayacak mı? Bak daha net görmen için
dönen üçgeni yani dönmüş halini şöyle
boyayalım. Biliyorsun boyamayı severiz.
Tamam. Şöyle daha net olur. Şimdi m
dedik. Başka? Hım. 3üncü açıya geleceğim
ama bir dur. Şimdi gençler bu arkadaş
80° dönmedi mi? 80° döndüyse şimdi bak
beni çok dikkatli takip et. C açısını
konuşacağız. C'nin sağ kolu burada
buraya gelmiş. Yeni dönmede döndükten
sonra işte o zaman bu dönme kaç
dereceydi? Ben sana sorarım. Sen bu
açıyı söyleyebilirsin bana. Kaç? 80.
Aynen öyle. Hemen yapıştırıyorsun. Bak
şurası ne olacak? 80° olacak. Dönme
açısı 80 olduğu için. E sen bana burayı
vermiştin. 108 demiştin değil mi? Orayı
tamamını B üssü C'den A'ya kadar.
Dolayısıyla bu küçük kardeşimize de yani
şuralara da ne kaldı? 28 kaldı. Tamam.
108'den 80'e düştüm 28. Hemen orayı da
şıp badanak yazı verdik. Onun dışında
bir şey daha demiştik. Kenar uzunlukları
da değişmeyecek demiştik. Yani şu BC
kenarı E B üssü C oldu. Bir şey mi
değişti? Yani dönerken sıcaklığa maruz
kalıp çekecek mi bu kenar? Hayır. Aynı
kenar gitti. O zaman şurasına da ben M
açısı diyebilir miyim? Çünkü ikizkenar
üçgen çıktı. Burası bak ikiz. Bu da
cepte. Onun dışında şimdi başka başka ne
yapabiliriz? M'yi bulduk. X'i bulduk. M
+ X'i söyleyebiliriz sanırım. Nereden?
Şu sarı boyalı arkadaşa bak. Burada bana
m + x'i söyleyebilirsin. Biraz da m'yi
de buluruz. Biraz oyalanayım istedim bu
sorudan niyeyse. Eee, 72 değil mi? 72
ise o zaman C açısını bulduk galiba.
Dikkat. Şurası bak. M + X'i de
barındıran arkadaş. M + X açısını buldun
sen. 72. Nereden bulmuştuk? Boyalı
üçgenden yola çıkarak. Tamam. Çünkü
bunun tepe açısı 108 vermiş. E yani
aslında bunu yapmaya da gerek yoktu. C
açısı o zaman 108 değil midir?
Dolayısıyla C açımız 108. Tamam. Şimdi
şimdi burası şöyle göstereyim. Bak
dönmeden önceki hali. Tamam mı? Şurası
108. Bak kırmızıyla kollarını çizdim.
Sen 28'ini aldın. O zaman buraya ne
kaldı? 80 kaldı. Geçmiş olsun. M'yi de
bulduk. Tamam. Al şu soldaki üçgenin
içine gir. Tepe açısı 80 ise ikizlere
100 düşer. Demek ki bir tanesi 50'ymiş.
Şimdi bir tanesi 50 ise m'yi 50 buldun
demektir. O zaman X'e de ne kaldı? 32°
kaldı. Tamam. Böyle akıttık akıttık
sorumuzu çözüme de ulaşmış olduk. Tabii
yaşlılığın verdiği bir [kahkaha]
şey sebebiyle eee 22 olması gerekeni 32
yazmış. Hiç de demiyorsunuz değil mi? Şu
an bence bir 30 kişi en az yorumlara
yazmıştır zaten. Hocam 32'ydi, yanlış
buldun. 22 olacaktı orası falan. Neyse
düzelttik. 4. soru da tamam. Geldik 5'e.
Şimdi gençler burada bir dikdörtgeni
alıyoruz. Dur alalım hemen dikdörtgeni.
Gel gel dikdörtgenimiz şöyle yapıştır.
Tamam. Karton köşegenlerinden biri
boyunca aa hemen bir köşegende şöyle
cart diye çizeyim. Düzelt. Harikasın.
Buradan kesiyoruz ve elde edilen
üçgenler aralarında boşluk kalmayacak ve
üst üste gelmeyecek şekilde kenarlarına
yapıştırıldığında aşağıdaki görsel elde
ediliyormuş. Şimdi bu iki üçgene bir
kere ne diyebiliriz? Eş üçgenler
diyebilir miyiz? 90 dereceleri var.
Köşegen uzunlukları ikisi için de aynı.
Kısalar aynı. Şöyle uzunlar yine
ikisinde de var. Dolayısıyla birebir eş
üçgenler diyebiliriz.
Onun dışında o zaman ne yapıyormuşuz?
Kırmızı renkle boyanan açıyı
bulacakmışız. Şimdi bak burada yani
basit düşünelim. Şu arkadaş yatay duran
şurası değil mi? Tamam. O zaman hani şu
açıyı m dediğini düşünürsem burada m
açımız var. Diğeri de n açısı olsun. Ve
biz bu arkadaşı ne yapıyoruz? Sol tarafa
değil sağ tarafa yerleştiriyoruz. Dikey
bir şimdi. E tamam o zaman. Orada da N
açısı buraya geliyor. Tepeye. E şimdi
sen bana söyle. Kırmızı boyalı yer m + n
değil midir? Evet. M + n dikdörtgenin
köşesi değil mi? Evet. E dolayısıyla
90°. Bu kadar geçtim. Şimdi kenar açı
kenara bakalım. Üçgenlerin gençler iki
kenarının ve dikkat bu kenarlar
arasındaki açının eşit olması üçgenlerin
eş olması için yeterlidir. Asgari
koşullardan birisidir. Şimdi ABC DF
üçgenlerinden iki kenar uzunlukları eşit
ve bu kenarlar arasındaki açı da eşit.
Bak 6 102 8 6 102 8 Ben bunu görüyorsam
iki üçgende de derim ki siz eşsiniz.
Tamam mı? Siz birebir aynısınız. Çünkü
diğer açılarda otomatikman aynı çıkacak.
Dolayısıyla şunu yazabilir. Bak bunu
yazarken yalnız dikkat ediyorum. Mesela
A'dan başlamış. A nerede? Şurası. Ondan
sonra B'ye gitmişim, değil mi? A'dan
B'ye. Yani önce 8 olan kenarı yazmışım
ve gidişatım 102 dereceye doğru. O zaman
diğerinde de yazarken önce D''yi
yazacağım ve 8 olan kenarı tamamlayıp
102 dereceye gideceğim. Yolculuğumuz bu
şekilde. İlk iki harfi buldun mu? 3üncü
zaten ne kaldı? 3üncü kaldı. Yazsın,
geçeceksin. Şimdi hemen sorusuna
bakalım. 6. sorumdayım. Şöyle karşımda
ne görüyorum? İki tane üçgen kardeşler
var. He e demiş. Ha bunu nokta ile
göstermişiz zaten. Tamam. Dap dap da
şurası iki tane onluğum var. Şöyle şöyle
6 var. 12 var. 2 var. Tamam. X'i
soruyor. Şimdi bak bunu nereden buluruz?
Bunu nereden bulacağız? Hemen şöyle
yapalım. Birincisi ben şurada bir 10
gördüm. Nokta açısı sonra 12 gördüm.
Sana gördün değil mi? Kenar açı kenar 10
nokta 12. Şimdi ben bunu bir yerde daha
görüyorum. O da şurası bak. 10. Tamam
mı? Sonra nokta ve 12'lik kenar. 10 10
nokta ve 12. Burada da gördüm. O zaman
diyorum ki bu yan yana duranlar
birbirine benzemiş. Üzüm üzüme baka baka
da kararı zaten değil mi? Aynı şey körle
yatan şaşı kalkar. Çok fazla atasüz var.
Şimdi dolayısıyla burada
x'i bulabilirim ben. Nasıl bulacağım? E
verilmeyen kenarım kim var? Noktanın
karşısı x. Noktanın karşısı 6. Demek ki
x neymiş? 6'ymış. Easy. 6. soru ne
çıkacaktı? 6 yazacağız tabii. Geldim
7'ye. Şimdi eşkenar üçgen var. Aa,
eşkenar görünce hemen soru kolaymış gibi
düşünüyorsun ama bu da stresli
sorularımızdan birisi. Şimdi bak şurası
60 diyebilirim bir kere. A, B, Cem
eşkenar, eee, işte şurası 60, tepe 60.
Bunları yazabiliriz. Onun dışında ADE
demiş. İki çizgiyle gösterdiğimiz şu
ikisi de aynı. X'in kaç derece olduğu
soruluyor. Hadi bakalım. Ne yapacağız?
Şimdi burada ben şöyle yapsam bak. Bu
eşit kenarlara M desem lan şuraya da N
diyelim bak. Şuraya da N dedim. Yani bir
eşkenar üçgenin bir kenarına ne demiş
oldum? M + N demiş oldum. Bu bir cepte
dursun. Şimdi gençler
dikkatli bakacak olursak M + N'den yola
çıktım. 60 dereceyi gördüm. Sonra da M
kenarını gördüm. Bununla aynı olan başka
bir şey var mı? Ona bakıyorum. Şimdi bu
kenarım da M + N. Tamam mı? Ne
yapacaktık? m + n'yi tamamlayıp 60'a
gidecektik. Tamam. O zaman onu şöyle de
yapamaz mıyım? Bak m + n'yi tamamladım.
60°ereceye gittim. Tepe açı 60 değil mi?
Eşkenar üçgendeyiz.
Yani şuraya geldim. Sonra da M'ye
gittim. Olur. Birebir eş üçgenlerimi
yakaladım. Hatta bunu boyuyorum. Tamam
mı? Bu benim eş üçgenlerimden birisi.
Diğerini de boyuyorum. O da şu bak. m +
n 60'a gittim. Sonra da m kenarını
çizdim. Dolayısıyla bu arkadaşı da
boyadım. Benim benim eş üçgenlerim
ortaya çıktı. Şimdi bunlardan
faydalanacağız. Bunların meyvesini
alacağız. Yalnız çok kötü boyamışım. İlk
defa böyle oluyor. Normalde hiç böyle
olmaz ama sen mevzuyu anladın. Hangi
üçgenlerin eş olduğunu anladın. Ben
temiz temiz devam etmek istiyorum. Şimdi
bundan sonra ne yapabilirim? Öncelikle
60° yani bu kenar açı kenar eşliğini
kullanmam lazım. Buradan eş üçgenlerim
açılarımı açılarımı da yazmam lazım.
60'lar zaten ikisinde de var. Şunu
silelim kafa karıştırmasın. Şurası da
60. Tamam. Onun dışında şuradaki m
kenarı m + n'den başlamıştık ya hani ilk
başladığımız. Hatta biz o üçgenleri
yazalım mı? Şöyle bak. A üçgeni. Tamam
mı? Bak ne yapıyorum önce m + n kenarı
sonra 60'a gidiyorum. Burada da m + n
kenarı 60'a gidiyorum. Yani C
sıralamasını yazacağım. C A sıralamasını
yazacağım. Bunlar diyeceğim ki eş
olduklarını ben bunların gördüm. Bunu
ispatladım. Şimdi buna göre açıları
yazabilirim. Mesela birinci de A açısı
sonra C açısına eşit. Eee, çok küçük
olacak ama dur ya iyice küçültelim. Gel
kalemi seç. Küçül küçül küçül küçül de
cebime gir. Şimdi şu açıya alfa dersem
tamam bak A açısına alfa dedim. C açısı
da caddaki C açısı yani şu ufaklık. Bu
da alfa değil mi? Evet bu da alfa.
Şimdi onun dışında bana şunu da söyler
misin? Tepe açımız bizim yani şu
eşkenarlıktan dolayı 60 değil miydi? O
zaman şurası 60 - alfa olmadı mı? Oldu.
Soru bitti.
Soru bitti. Şimdi göremiyorsun değil mi
hocam? Nasıl bitti? Soru şurada bitti.
Şu lan çok büyük verme bana. Küçültün
şunları ya. Hah. Şurada bak şu üçgene
bak. Tamam mı? Şu üçgende
iki açı yazdın sen değil mi? Ne var bu
iki açının? Bir de dışı var. Ve biz ne
biliyoruz? İki iç açının
toplamı bir dış açıya eşittir. Yani x
neye eşitmiş? alfa + 60 - alf'ya
alfaları pazara gönderir. X'e de 60°
der. Olayı da bitirirsin. Tamam. İnceci
bir soruydu. Dikkat etmek lazım. Bu
şekilde çözdük. Peki devam. Hemen geldim
8'e. Şimdi bir dörtgen var karşımızda.
108° var. Tamam. İşte iki açı eşitliği
neresi? Bu noktalarla göstermiş miyiz?
BA. Tamam. Ve CAD. Tamam. ABD kenarı. SS
gösterilmiş. X'in kaç derece olduğu
soruluyor. Kask. Bakalım. Şimdi yine ne
görüyorum ben? İki yani şu S kenarlarını
boşluğuna vermedik eşit diye. Bir de açı
vermişiz. Utanmadın. Daha ne istiyorsun
diye sorarlar adama. Şimdi burada bak
B'den başlıyorum nokta açıma gidiyorum.
B'den başladım nokta açıma gittim ve
C'ye doğru yolculuğumuzu tamamlayalım.
veya üçgeni. Diğer tarafta da yine
D''den baş yani S kenarından başlıyorum.
Nokta açısına gidiyorum. Yani DA sonra
C'ye gittiğimde
ne görüyorum gençler?
Bu kenarla ikisi için aynı değil mi? O
zaman bu iki üçgen eştir diyebilirim.
Bak bir daha söylüyorum. S kenarı nokta
açısı AC.
S kenarı, nokta açısı AC. İkisinde de
aynı şeyi aynı sıralamayla söyledim. O
zaman siz kardeşsiniz. Yani eşsiniz
diyorum. Ve dolayısıyla
ne diyeceğiz? Şu S'in karşısındaki açı
yani şurası
da ne olur? X olur. Neden? Karşısında da
çünkü öyle. O zaman burada olayı
bitirdik. 360° var ve dolayısıyla 108 +
2x 360'a eşit. At burada 108'i karşıya
tekmeledim. Kaç gitti? 360'tan 108'i
çıkarıp söylesenize hemen. Niye beni
yoruyorsunuz ya? Burası 2 5 25 mi? 252.
O zaman x'i de ne buluruz? 126° bulur.
Geçer gideriz. O nasıl derece ya? Şöyle.
Hadi devam. Şimdi sonuncu arkadaşa
geldik. Açı kenar açı. Hım. Hım. Burada
ne diyeceğiz? Bak şimdi 3. İç açısı
bilinen biliyorsunuz sonsuz tane üçgen
çizilebilir. Yani üçgen eşitsinde bunu
biliyoruz. Yani üçgen çiziminde geçen
sene de görmüştük ya. Üç açı. Bunu
aklına şöyle getirebilirsin. 60 60.
Şimdi sen farklı çizersin, ben farklı
değil mi? Küçük bir eşkenar üçgen ya da
devasa bir eşkenar üçgen çizebiliriz. eş
diyemeyiz. Yani üç açısı bilinen sonsuz
tane çizilebilir.
İşte bu sebepten ötürü iki üçgenin
karşılıklı açıların ölçülerinin eşit
olması üçgenlere eş dememiz için yeterli
değildir. Tamam tabii ki de bunu isteriz
ama sadece açıları eşit diye de eş
diyemeyiz. Dolayısıyla
karşılıklı iki açı ölçüsü ve bir kenar
uzunluğunun eşit olması bizim için iki
üçgenin eş olmasının asgari
koşullarından biridir. Yani mutlaka bir
kenar uzunluğu bana vereceksin. Tamam. E
hocam iki tane de açı var. 3üncü açı.
3üncü açı zaten otomatikman aynı
çıkmıyor mu? 20 30 e 3üncüye nokta
düştü. 20 30 3üncüye nokta düştü. Tamam.
3üncü açı aslında iki açının verilmesi
otomatikman 3 açı verilmesi demektir.
Dolayısıyla üçgenlerin eşliği. E aynı
açının karşısındaki kenarlarım da
tamamsa geçmiş olsun diyeceğim. Bu iki
üçgen E=
bakalım sorumuza. Şimdi 9. soruya
baktım.
Ne görüyoruz?
İki tane üçgenimiz var. EDB ve JAP
açıları. Neredeymiş onlar? EDB nokta ve
da yine nokta nokta gösterilmiş. AE
şurası es kenarı C de es kenarı bunlar
eşit. Bir tane 4 cmimiz var. X'in ne
olduğu soruluyor. Bakalım şimdi bir kere
tabii ki de en fazla bilginin olduğu
yere çullanacağız. Klasik matematik soru
çözüm yöntemimizdir bu taktik. Bu nerede
fazla bilgi? Üstüne yapış. Şimdi burada
bak ha bir kere şunu gördük mü? Bak
burada bir ters açı var. Ters açı. Şöyle
iki çizgi yapalım. Bunlar eşit. Orada
bir x var. Karşılıklı eşit olacak.
Açılar eşit olacak. Dolayısıyla hatta
tarayalım mı? Şöyle daha şey gözüksün.
Net gözüksün. Şöyle taradım. Şimdi bak
es kenarımı geçtim. Nokta açıma geldim.
Sonra da iki çizgiye gidiyorum. S
kenarından nokta açısına. Sonra iki
çizgiye. E burada da aynı şeyi
yapabiliyor muyum? S kenarından çıktım.
Nokta açısına geldim. Nokta açısından da
diğerine gidiyorum. Demek ki bu iki
üçgenin ne diyeceğim? Birebir
tüm iç açıları aynı. Tamam. Şimdi bunu
dedikten sonra o zaman nasıl devam
ediyorum? Diyorum ki bana kenar uzunluğu
lazım. Yani üç açısını bilmem yeterli
değil ki. Neyse ki kenar uzunluğu da
var. E S kenarı işte ikisinde de var.
Bak karalamanın karşısı S, karalamanın
karşısı S. Tamam. 3 açı içinde bir tane
de bana kenar attırmış. O zaman şimdi
gönül rahatlığıyla ağzımız dolu dolu. Bu
iki üçgene eştir diyebiliriz. Peki bu
bize ne sağlar? Şunu sağlar. Soruyu
bitirir. Noktanın karşısında 4 var.
Noktanın karşısında 4 olacak. X'i 4
bulduk. Geçtik diyebiliriz. Tamam. Şimdi
güzel sağlam bir diğer sorumuza geldik.
Bak iki tane kare var. içe geçmiş işte.
FB 3,5 demiş ve ABCD karesinin alanı
soruluyor. Şimdi çok dikkat ediyorsun.
Bir kere en dıştaki de kare olduğu için
burada bir 90 derecem var. Burada
açılara şöyle m ve n desem içerideki de
90 değil mi gençler? Değil mi? Onu da
bir yazalım. Şimdi sen bana söyler
misin? Burada M ve N sağ alttaki üçgene
bakıyorsun. FEB. FEB'ye bakıyorsun. Bu
üçgene bakarak bana şunu söyleyebilir
misin? M ve N açılarının toplamı 90°
değil mi? 90°. Neden? Çünkü üçgenin iç
açıları toplamı 180. 190 zaten köşede
var. Onu düş. O zaman diğerlerine de 90
kalacak. İkisinin toplamına. Bu cepte.
Şimdi gel şuraya bak. Burası bir doğru
açı değil mi? Evet. 180° normalde. E
bunun ortasının 90'ı var. O zaman bunu
düşersem sağdaki ve soldaki açı toplamı
90 olması lazım. Çok güzel. Bir tanesi N
ise N'yi 90'a kim tamamlıyor? M
tamamlıyor. O yüzden buraya da hemen M
diyebiliyorum. Şimdi soldaki üçgen
diyeyim. Tamam. Çorap söküğü gibi akıyor
soru. Burada da köşemiz 90 değil mi?
Kare olduğu için. Çok güzel. Şimdi he ae
üçgeninde ae ahe üçgeninde 90'ım var.
Diğer iki açıya da o zaman 90 düşmeyecek
mi ikisinin toplamına? Aa bir tanesi
MYmiş. O zaman diğerinde ne kaldı? Ne
kaldı? Söylüyoruz ya işte ne kaldı
şimdi? Dolayısıyla Dolayısıyla şuradaki
üçgenle buradaki üçgeni tüm iç açıları
ölçüleri eşittir. Ne işimize yarayacak
hocam? Eşkenar üçgenlerin de hepsinin iç
açıları eşit. Bana kenar lazım. Çok
güzel. Şimdi mevzuyu anladık. O zaman
kenar bakacağız kendimize. E burada
içerideki arkadaş kare değil miydi? O
zaman EF uzunluğuyla
EH uzunluğu aynı değil midir? Yani benim
o eş dediğim iki üçgen için 90'ın
karşısındaki kenar uzunlukları eşit
çıkmadı mı? Ne olduğu önemli değil ama
eşit çıktı. O zaman artık gönül
rahatlığıyla ağzımız dolu dolu. Bu iki
üçgen eştir diyebiliriz. Peki eşse artık
tamamlayalım. Niğde'nin karşısı Nide'nin
karşısı
Muğla'nın karşısı 5, Muğla'nın karşısı
5. Geçmiş olsun. Kenar uzunluğum 3. 5
daha 8 oldu. Dolayısıyla ABCD'nin bir
kenarını buldum. Alanını da bulurum. 8in
karesinden 64cm².
Temiz. Last question diyor muyuz o
zaman? Bence diyoruz. Hadi bakalım.
Şimdi burada ne yapacağız?
İkizkenar üçgen denmiş. Güzel. Kimler
ikiz? Bu ikizler hangi köyün ikizleri?
AB AC'ye eşitmiş. Güzel. Şu iki arkadaş
eşitmiş. Hemen notlarımızı alıyoruz. Şu
üçgen karalama yaptım. Tamam mı? Açı
daha doğrusu. C açısını da karalama
açısı yaptım. Aa ne göreyim? Bak
karalamaların yanında bir de nokta var.
O zaman 3üncü açılara da şöyle çizgi ve
çizgi yapabilirim. Dikkat ettin mi?
Şuradaki üçgende nokta çizgi karalama,
buradaki üçgende de nokta çizgi karalama
açıları var. 3 /3te bu iki arkadaş açı
aça açı hepsi eşit.
Şimdi eş üçgen diyemiyorum ama yani bana
ne lazım? Kenar uzunluğu. Hemen kontrol
ediyoruz. Kenar uzunluklarımızda bir
sıkıntı var mı? Bakalım. Soldan daldım.
Çizginin karşısında aa iki çizgi kenarı
var. Çizgi açımın karşısında aa iki
çizgi kenarı var. Kenar da var. Açıların
eşliğinin yanında bir tane de kenar
uzunluğum aynıysa artık gönül
rahatlığıyla bu iki üçgen eştir
diyebiliriz. Şimdi tamamla. Noktanın
karşısı 10. Noktanın karşısı 10. Aha
ikizkenarın bir ikizini buldum. 14
cepte. Şimdi karalamanın karşısı 8.
Karalamanın karşısı burada da yine 8.
Ama çizginin karşısı yani şu iki çizgi
dediği yere bilmiyoruz. X diyelim. Buna
da X diyeceğiz mecbur. Ve artık soruyu
çözeceğiz. Ne sormuş bize? Demiş ki ABC
üçgeninin çevre uzunluğu EDC üçgeninin
çevresinden ne kadar fazladır? E hocam
bilinmeyen var ya. Bir dursun. Bir
dursun bakalım. Şimdi şurası da 14. Bu
arada ikizkenar olduğu için ben galiba
ABC çevresini yazabilirim. Çevre ABC
üçgeni eşittir E burası 14 burası 28 eee
şurada da 10 + x var 28 şu 38 yani 38 +
x diyebilirim. Bir de diğerini söyle
bakalım. Çıtlat onu da bize. Kimdi o
EDC? EDC'yi de yazdım. Kim var burada?
Eee, şöyle 8 var, 10 var, 18 + x
diyeceğim.
Şahane. İşte bu ikisi arasındaki farkı
sormuş. Çıkarma yaparken zaten ne
olacak? Fark ettin değil mi? X'ler
birbirini gönderecek pazara. 38 + X - 18
- X'ten X'ler gitti. 38 - 18'den cevabı
20cm olarak bulmuş olduk. Dersi de
burada ne yaptık? Noktaladık. Şimdi seni
neye göndereceğim? Bir şeye
göndermeyeceğim. 20. dersimizde tekrar
görüşelim diyeceğim. Tamam mı? Gel şöyle
ana ekrana. 20. derste benzerlik
bakacağız. Tamam mı? Benzer olma
koşullarından bahsedeceğiz yine. Eee
orada da sağlam hele son sorular çok
sağlam sorularımız var. Onları
çözeceğiz. Sonra da artık uygula,
pekiştir, yazılı sorularımıza
geçebileceğiz. Tamam. Evet gençler,
sevgili 9 ne yapıyorsun? Dediğim gibi
hala edinmediysen eee önümüzdeki sene
değişimler yapacağız. Dolayısıyla artık
stoklarımız sınırlı. Onu da söylemiş
olayım. Kapağı mapağı değişecek. O
yüzden eee haberin olsun. Yani içerik
değiştirmeyeceğiz çok fazla ama kapak
vesaire değişeceğinden dolayı yeni baskı
yapmıyoruz. Hani işin özü bu.
Dolayısıyla da sınırlı kalan stoklar
için tekrar hatırlatmış olayım.
Derslerimize gördüğün gibi 20. derse
geçeceğiz. Devam ediyoruz. Hala değilsen
abone olmayı unutma. Hala buradaysan şu
dakikaya kadar videoyu beğenmeden
çıkmazsan çok sevinirim. Yorumlarınızı
da bekliyorum. konularda mesela
neredesiniz? Bir ileridesin diyen var.
Bir geride kaldınız hocam diyen var.
Şöyle bir ortalamayı da nabzı tutalım.
Konuları da yazarsan eee yorum attığın
an itibariyle hangi konudasın onu da
söylersen çok sevinirim. Tamam. Hadi
bakalım canlar. Ne diyoruz o zaman? Bir
sonraki derste yeniden görüşünceye dek
kendinize çok iyi bakın ve matematikle
kalın. Hoşça kalın.
he